what I'll try to do is I'll just write
longhand it on so on a legal pad I'll go
goes to here sees his mother goes to the
store because so I'll have like ten
things of beats where he's going now
gets on a horse go swimming bumble bow
and I do that and I know in my heart
eighty percent of it will be no good but
you're getting through the screenplay
you're getting it done because the
rewrite is always more fun and much more
enjoyable it's I don't believe people
should look for perfection or even 50%
profession in the first draft it's
always going to be kind of this like a
child scribbling but you did it and the
main thing for me is to once you have
that accomplished when I say in two you
could do it in two weeks three weeks
again maybe 10% will be good but you've
now have this sense of accomplish you
did it and the rewriting process starts
and that's when the fun begins
I truly believe and people throw the
word around dreams it's it's all about
dreams you know and by the way dreams
cost nothing if they're free the hard
part is just keeping them going and
please keep them going because we're
here for one simple reason if our dreams
come true and there's no reason every
one of yours can't either
you just watch - amazing clips from
Sylvester Stallone take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]